There's a worldwide plastic production
of 350 million tons a year.
And about 300 million tons
are ending up as waste.
We've put billions of tons, actually,
of plastic into the environment.
By 2050 people have
predicted that there'll be
more plastic in the ocean
than fish in terms of weight.
Remnants of our products
have spread to every corner of the planet.
With both global production of plastics
and the cost of recycling
rising, the outlook is bleak.
But our planet has a remarkable
way of fighting back.
Recently discovered
plastic-eating bacteria
has given scientists hope.
Hope to decontaminate our planet
and make cleaner products
for the future.